okay now let's meet to the same
prescription and hes ray that was a
little more detail expected pretty
standard sort of question right discuss
social network issues for marks for
Mark's looking for when we looking for
very roughly speaking I'm looking for
two positives and two negatives what
that translates to is I am looking for
you to demonstrate good enough
understanding the situation you can see
it's not just all wow this is the best
thing ever and it's not just all well
this is terrible big brother's taking
you over that kind of thing I want you
to show me a multi-faceted understanding
the situation okay now here's what I'm
going to do right I just give you a list
of the issues that you could have
thought of even a sort of i'm going to
give that to i'm going to try and show
you how i built my list by looking at
the question because most people say to
me oh man i just have trouble sort of
coming up with like thinking up ideas
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to once I figure out what my pages
I'm gonna work through this I think I've
got how many do I come up with one two
three four five six six issues i could
probably car with more if i kept
thinking for a bit longer and i was
really looking for four and out of these
six some of them go both ways okay so
how can we see the issues within the
information that the question is given
to you okay so let's walk through it
again another car little dude ok so I'm
going to start just by reading it and I
want to read it through the lens are
okay how does it affect people how
people related this surround pics is an
online service that creates virtual
tools on on behalf of real estate agents
and their clients all right there's my
first issue now I think ironically it's
my misspelled word but the crucial word
here is on behalf of okay and then you
get these other guys real estate agents
okay now how is this an issue what is
the issue whenever you've got now marked
this by the way because this happens a
lot whenever you've got technology
companies and often technology copies
are not doing things for themselves
they're doing it on behalf of others
okay so that one behalf of right means
you've got multiple parties right one
company's doing something for another so
here's my question all of this stuff
this information right who owns it hmm
all of this data who owns it now it's a
tricky question because there's a lot of
different data here the live different
kinds and data but the question remains
that the question the issue is ownership
ownership of data that's a big deal
that's a big issue ok key you see how it
relates how could you argue that you've
got you've got different groups of
people wear different groups of people
number one this company's surround Peaks
number to reverse their agents number
three clients at the very least right
there explicitly new okay now can you
see we could argue that each of the
three are the people who should own the
data or different parts of the done how
would you argue that surround pics
should be the owners don't you go about
argument yeah they're those ceramics no
cool panorama thing right like if they
didn't do like the act of putting it all
together and then writing this software
that stitches it and then make it
available they don't wouldn't exist so
like of course it's their data right but
at the same time how would you argue the
real estate agents on the dot what why
would you argue yeah that's right i
bought this thing right it's mine cuz i
pay you know so I engaged you for a
service okay so it's like it's like
going to you know dokie and you're like
I'd like a like a thick shake please and
you pay the money and then they're like
here's the thick shake at that you can't
have it it's mine I made it IV I created
it you know you know me no big shake
okay it's a ludicrous out of it right so
clearly the money that's involved in yet
we
paid you guys we commissioned you to
make this that's got to be involved in
some way okay lastly you know the
clients okay why would the client I mean
what I'm talking about the owners of the
property right why would in what way do
they have a stake in learning this data
this is interesting because most is here
companies are not that bigger this kind
of thing but if I make a file photo
story I'll take pictures in that sort of
thing and upload them somewhere my
second the initial creation of the data
means I'm the main stakeholder right
it's my person about it's my address
it's my house this is my stuff okay so
whatever you make out of it is still in
some way mine okay now those three words
in some way they're everything right now
you don't have to answer that question
because the question is just discuss the
issues so all you have to do is raise
the question who owns this it could be
these guys are these guys are these guys
and it's not clear okay in this case I
think mall in most cases it would really
be governed by the contract that these
guys agree on right they would put it
down and write it right and surround
pics my tech we are entitled owned this
that the other and so on okay maybe the
photos remain the property of the
photographer or something like that okay
but there's an issue number one who's in
the first line first sentence all right
let's keep going now before we move on
to more words have a look at this have a
look at this just this diagram here okay
on the screen shot what kinds of issues
jump out of you when you look at this
screen shot
they pose this question to you you're at
home in the evening just finished dinner
or something like that and here knock at
the door okay so you go to answer right
cuz you know parents are two layers of
doing the cells in like a go go get the
door okay so you go open it and there's
a complete stranger at the door and they
just sort of stand there and look at you
you let you try to sort them out you
like is he like a delivery guy or like I
tell him like not till I got a
door-to-door salesman so like that and
they don't let it say anything they just
stand there and look at you and they're
like sort of a pass to you look inside
your house now let me ask you this would
you invite said we'd 0 into your house
probably got if you were think again I
would you probably should it okay now
why okay for obvious reason that you
don't want them you know coming here
hasn't like you know take your stuff in
that kind of thing but even just for the
reason that you don't want them to have
access to your house you know with him
to see your stuff you don't want them to
be able to see where all the things out
what if they're like a thief worth a
robber they're trying to suss you know
the area out like oh there's TV I know
where to get that one from well you know
those kinds of things they have a look
at this this is like a robbers dream
right it's like oh look here are all the
windows and here is the easiest door to
get large objects out that kind of be
okay oh and who is this available to
who's just about every this is public
public okay now even though you might
say okay look come on these guys are
trying to sell their houses obviously
like the real estate agents okay so if
you try to sell your house you know
people like that they have them they'd
your open homes right so they invite
people win they make a big thing about
it the more people who come the better
because they want more buyers they can
think but there's a big line between
opening up that which is still sort of a
public event on to this kind of public
know so it's going to say publicity mr.
I'm going to work okay I mean for
starters when you got an open home if
you walk in you have to register your
name and address in contact details
right so there's a record of who you are
and your entrance into that building
whereas here anyone in their IP address
can just come along
right so there's a big privacy issue
here privacy right I think that was
pretty obvious one so a lot of people
said it all right let's